Since the inclusion by the Security Council of child protection...
...in the mandate of peacekeeping operation,...
...tireless efforts of our civilian and uniformed personnel...
...have transformed the lives of countless boys and girls.
Peacekeepers have engaged in in dialogue with parties to conflict...
...to halt and prevent grave violations against children.
For example, in August last year in Mali,...
...action plans were signed with a coalition of our movements...
...to end and prevent the recruitment and use of children.
In the Democratic Republic of Congo, up to 2,500 children, including over 350 girls,...
...were voluntarily released by armed groups in just the past three and a half years...
...as a result of dedicated joint efforts.
Peacekeepers have played a crucial role in helping monitor...
...and report on grave violations against children,...
...and they continue to ensure that child protection aspects...
...are included in peace negotiations and agreement.
The protection of children is at the heart of UN peacekeeping.
Despite the extreme challenges they face every day,...
...our peacekeepers remain determined to play their part...
...in protecting boys and girls affected by armed conflict.
As we look to the future,...
...we should never forget that maintaining peace, security and stability...
...is the best way to protect children...
...and that, in turn, protection of children...
...is essential to building lasting peace and stability for all.